[Music]
all right this lady recently got
arrested changer she got caught in a
money-making scheme oh where she would
purchase flight delay and shop and then
look into which flights to look that she
had she had anticipated that it would
eventually get delayed this happened
from 2015 to 2019 so back when the world
was normal and she actually she took out
almost 900 flight delay insurance
policies and she made bank
I think she's genius like apparently is
illegal is it illegal in China or cuz I
know that this happened in China yeah I
read this article before something was
illegal part of its industrious yeah
she's doing exactly what go fighting to
me I'm like what is the difference
between that and an extreme couponer or
someone who goes for all the deals or
they look for the loopholes in gambling
and technically it's not illegal but
then they know how to beat the house I
knew we'd deals people were there trying
to get us to they weren't put us all in
jail no she would actually use 20 other
identities in addition that's the legal
part okay she would do all this and so
she has she has past travel service
experience work experience I see oh she
was able to select specific she's an
insider yeah so yeah it's kind of
insider trading kind of thing that's not
fair okay I don't read really deep into
it because if I knew that I would have
backed you up she's illegal yeah that
part was illegal everything else so you
know that's kind of so impressive just
let her keep it yeah cuz she did a lot
of research it was research on checking
for extreme weather or delayed inducing
events on flight routes route and she
got a good amount of money - how much
was it like four hundred thousand or
some sugar was it four hundred thousand
they should actually pay her for finding
a broken system and have and helping fix
it instead of paying her though she got
arrested but these companies did close
up those loopholes that allowed her to
get away with it or welcome yeah no
thank you to her
yeah ungrateful I would've gave her a
free [ __ ] years worth of flights
lifetime she's not gonna use it anyway
or give her a whole year with the
flights and the light delay isn't one of
them don't let her buy insurance on
those [ __ ] no one else could book those
flights but bumper when's her flight
Wednesday maybe so aside from the
identity fraud do you think she did
something morally wrong though no I mean
it's stealing how was it stealing she
scammed large amounts of money from this
insurance she knows that it's she's
lying right because she knows that she's
not gonna get on this flight she knows
that if she says his flight was delayed
that she wasn't even planning on getting
on this she's gonna get this return on
it that she's collecting insurance on
something with the ill intent exactly
what is it stick up for big business do
good for you I'm just saying I'm just
calling it as I see it and I'm just
twisting your words into something that
you didn't even say I appreciate that
yeah there you go I would just make me
excuse like every time I was supposed to
leave for my flight I had to [ __ ] really
bad I'm Asian and I'm lactose intolerant
and there you go you'd love a lot ice I
didn't lie I remember in high school
like the insurance fraud being to get
into his car insurance fraud it was the
cool thing to do people are either
people people would either like say
their car got vandalized and you would
like scratch up the paint then you can
go to your homies shop and you can
they'll claim it they paint your car for
their cost so you're getting your new
paint job a body kit and all the stuff
that you want done but they get
insurance prices which is always like
three or four times the amount that
they're gonna charge anyways or those
the ones where you get into like fake
accidents and then you got to go to the
chiropractor put your neck hurts and you
talk to the chiropractor and you only go
like five sessions but then they charge
you for like ten sessions would you get
some of that money kickback - Wow the
nuts going on a lot in high school
sounds fraudulent high school the
smartest high school kids I ever heard
about kids I knew trying to set fire to
[ __ ] garbage cans of [ __ ] for summary
like what does it do for you man why are
you doing this at lunch so why yeah why
can't you be like these con artists high
school kids that are doing something
productive with their lives actually
making moves at least never that good of
a con it's something like a big business
thing you just get hired right dude
Franklin what hackers do Frank William
Abagnale did that dude catch me if you
can guy you called Niki autistic no no
no I just I'm just a fan I love I love
that whole story and everything and he
did the art of the steel which is a
great book if you ready what is it the
art of the steel part of oh that's what
that's where Trump got his an idea oh
yeah my family and I were in a group
chat yesterday talking about all the
dumb illegal [ __ ] we did and we were
younger like all the aunties [ __ ] you
better redraw the whole transcript the
volume baby race I wasn't anything crazy
like I think like four of us got caught
for shoplifting one of our teenagers
another one joyriding cars and [ __ ] and
then like just all the cousins on all
the aunties were just admitting their
[ __ ] I admitted to my aunt like hey
remember when used to go and check in my
room to make sure I went to school she's
like yeah I'm like I just sleep in my
closet and wait for you to leave yeah or
like smart I got is very smart actually
yeah and then I had my youngest aunt
come pick me up and she has to pretend
to be my guardian but she was only like
three years older than me I don't like
thanks for not telling the older auntie
it was great now that we're at this age
we can just admit it all you know what
Gina we met someone at June B remember
keep going what named them so you gave
her like almost zero Khan yeah for her
to know what you're talking we met
someone to do B yeah this person special
this person special so we we met someone
that Jim B and then she said that she
was a guidance counselor at Temple she
goes I know a lot of you guys went to
Temple and then she was like and I'm a
fan of all of you guys I've been
watching just he's always I watch her
vlogs long she's all the Asian lady and
then she was like oh by the way your
friend Gina she would always come in
with these fake parent notes these big
old smile she was just she brought this
bubbly personality that I just had to
pass
yeah she's like any other less fake the
whole time with her okay show me later
I'll just get fired from a couple number
I don't know oh gee I met a London club
owner that claimed he's a distant
relative of yours there's so many people
claiming all kinds of children
yes family in Texas yeah family in Texas
I don't know a London club owner no what
was it Boston I was okay true story I
was talking to my old man and I'm gonna
talk around this little bit this is
patreon video nope
so okay she knows me too I was talking
about old man so that just gives you
guys a little hint yeah awesome [ __ ] on
patreon we do spill some [ __ ] on patreon
a little hidden hint there but my my old
man grown up he was involved in a
certain thing he was not knowingly
involved in a certain thing is it bomb
backwards
did he hang out with people that were
like spaghetti something like that Oh
people like Italian recipes no so so I
was talking on the phone I was like hey
do you think the reason why these people
did this business was because they could
filter a fuckload cash through it and
that's why they like that and he changed
the subject we were on the phone so you
haven't seen a dinosaur before so it was
like I was like I was like in my inner
[ __ ] Scorsese movie like Doug I was
like he just closed the lines are tapped
brother the lizard no so that's what
saying but I'm like surely like the
statute of limitations has passed so
long it's still happening right now this
cat was like just brought up something
else he's not a rat like like other
people like some people are like some
people I just thought that was
fascinating like it also gave me chills
yeah my that's the same way too
I asked him a question once he's like
don't say - [ __ ]
answer that oh my yeah it's me because
even if you guys in person yeah it
wasn't person yeah I make the worst
gangster cuz I tilt
oh that was a kid my dad told me though
I was like you know what went on with
all that stuff and he was like I'll tell
you when you're 21 buy a beer at the bar
never 34 now are you ask again I'll tell
you dad you been lame all my life can
you do something cool give me some why
were you gone he's the guy why are you
gone while I grew up you know now he's a
guy from Goodfellas yeah we're talking
about has anything like that sorry Ray
Liotta mm-hmm he was an actor so he was
an actor and he would be in films and my
father father was a key grip he was best
boy yeah like the movie just you didn't
even give me that a good roll key grip
what what you need you need light of
course you need you're so disrespectful
to the lighting guys it's just in your
blood you you just took a whole industry
and [ __ ] all over it they know it you
know when you know you already just did
there
I took your words been twisted into
something you didn't mean I appreciate
that I appreciate you he's really good
at doing that so what you mean is we're
really saying so what you're really
saying is this isn't it Joseph I love
Joe sticking up for big business again
and not the real regular people because
apparently I'm a [ __ ] capitalism
[ __ ] mogul a monopoly man pigtails all
these something like a pig I feel like
the people that believe that they they
see no difference between like would
they look at me they see me with a fat
cigar laughing at a big top hat guy ah
I'm gonna own all around
you want me to give you the video of you
almost taking a [ __ ] in my front door
maybe you could keep playing sorry yeah
that's a great way excuse me we're not
gloss over this I need to understand I
said this a million times
long story short I had the diarrhea and
I was gonna explode and I was wondering
if I should [ __ ] on her Bush am I was
painful wait the plant outside in a
front door and you see in the you know
surveillance footage yeah
did you see it you're like actually like
he's cause you can see what's in is
going through his mind gonna do it you
know wasn't opening the [ __ ] door I
knew that they were sleeping I didn't
want to [ __ ] get the dogs to bark or
anything right why are you oh oh I train
in the morning with them something I'm
[ __ ] on your [ __ ] bushes and then
I was like wait oh no I think I [ __ ] in
my pants and I had to check my ass I
smell it so if we yeah if I give you
that video then you can give it to those
people that think you're with the cigar
because like no this is what I mean why
you really have your mother five es I
just want to know why you guys didn't
immediately upload that video because I
would have gone there it's a it's all
barren Channel I don't want to know so
all the time you know this Joe will you
be friends yeah a man so hard for you or
stick up for you try to get your tail
try to get you laid oh you know what it
thinks he just says that you're lame and
you can't do this [ __ ] on your own no
how in the [ __ ] do you tell a story like
this and you'll get [ __ ] DMS with
[ __ ] I didn't twist his words he said
I attract very kind women that are
understanding that people need a poop Oh
everybody shart see but ya never liked
having just singular ponytail
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]